I do Christmas almost all year round
just sharing the Christmas message of
Jesus JoJo siwa calls out Candace
Cameron Beret after the actress revealed
the GAC family Network where she serves
as Chief creative officer has no plans
to feature same-sex couples I love
having conversations with people who
have differing opinions than me that is
that's the I it's the best because I
want to hear how you feel about it
following Candace's departure from
Hallmark Channel the actress opened up
about making the jump to a new Christian
conservative Network Great American
Family telling wsj magazine that they
will keep traditional marriage at the
core well that didn't sit well with JoJo
who seemingly settled her beef with
Candace back in July after she named the
Full House star on Tick Tock as the
rudest celebrity she ever met so I was
finally able to talk to Jojo this
morning I called her and
and um we had a great conversation we
had all the feels and it was all good
and there was like there's no drama
um that's the T fast forward to Monday
and there's this new drama JoJo slamming
Candace's recent comments on Instagram
writing that Not only was her statement
rude it was hurtful to a whole community
of people quote honestly I can't believe
after everything that went down just a
few months ago that she would not only
create a movie with intention of
excluding lgbtqia plus but then also
talk about it in the Press
I can't handle fake people Candace's
Fuller house co-star Jody Sweden offered
her support to Jojo swooping into the
comments writing you know I love you
just made my heart
so happy meanwhile Candace's daughter
Natasha came to her mom's defense
calling the media a vile space for
negativity before applauding her mom for
how she handles herself with the utmost
Grace when her words are taken out of
context I want you to be able to listen
to how I feel about it but I want you to
say something that made me make me
change my mind but JoJo isn't the only
one speaking out dance with me are you
serious Hilary Burton blasted the
actress on Twitter calling her a bigot
and adding I don't remember Jesus liking
Hypocrites like candy but sure make your
money honey you ride that prejudice wave
all the way to the bank now that's a
little extreme before leaving for Great
American Family Candice starred in 29
holiday movies for Hallmark the network
makes history next month when Jonathan
Bennett stars in The Holiday sitter
which features their first leading gay
couple
you caught feelings they're not movies
about gay or straight they're just
movies about love family and people
first thing you mark
E.T was behind the scenes with Candace
last month for a Christmas present which
premieres on GAC on November 27th I hope
that it will remind them to take a
moment this Christmas to slow down and
just look at what's right in front of
their eyes
[Music]
thank you